[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم اجازه من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
السلام عليكم قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
تقتحم مدينه بيت لحم وتعتقل ثلاثه شبان
فلسطينيين تشتبه في اطلاقهم النار على
مستوطنين جنوبي نابلس ما ادى لاصابه ثلاثه
منهم وحركه حماس والجهاد تقولان ان
العمليه تؤكد صمود المقاومه واصرارها على
مواجهه الاحتلال في تطورات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا بايدن اعطى شركاء واشنطن
الاوروبيين ضوء اخضر لتدريب الاوكرانيين
على طائرات الاف 16 بينما لوحه بوتين
باستخدام الذخائر العنقوديه واعلن فشل
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بينما قالت ان
قواتها تقدمت في محور باخموت كفر السواحل
التونسيه يعلن وانقاذ اكثر من 100 طالب
لجوء اثناء محاولتهم عبور المتوسط الى
ايطاليا في وقت يزور فيه وفد اوروبي تونس
لبحث حزمه المساعدات الاوروبيه وقضايا عده
على راسها الهجره غير النظاميه
يكمل اجراءات التعاقد مع ليونيل ميسي حتى
نهايه الموسم 2025 وينشر مقطع فيديو
للترحيب رسميا بنجمه الجديد ومن المرجح ان
تكون مباراه مثل اولى يوم السبت المقبل
امامول المكسيكي في مسابقه الكاس الى
اللقاء